nuevamente los ojos puestos en
mineápolis a la espera de lo que sea un
juicio al oficial responsable del
arresto y posterior muerte de georg
floyd dar y chavín para el que mañana
empezará a seleccionarse el jurado van a
ser varias semanas para llegar a una
sentencia pero lo que ahora tenemos
claro es que las calles están pidiendo
justicia se quiere una sentencia
ejemplar una sentencia contundente y por
eso hay muchas voces que recuerdan lo
que el año pasado vivimos en estados
unidos que fue movilizaciones constantes
y agitación social en las calles ahora
mismo hemos presenciado una marcha donde
centenares de personas han estado
gritando alzando el puño recordando
aquella frase de no puedo respirar a
quién ruiz que pronunciaría floyd antes
de fallecer y también una concentración
religiosa varias iglesias se han juntado
para rezar para traer mensajes de paz
para lo que puede ser unas semanas
intensas donde mineápolis vuelve a ser
el centro de las miradas